well Europe is synonymous with rail
travel but it's often a bumpy ride for
passengers traveling between the rail
networks of bordering countries for one
network timetables are rarely integrated
with those neighboring countries that
often means long Waits at Borders
another problem is infrastructure rail
networks run on different Electric
Systems they have different signaling
systems even different gauges of tracks
that means that a train in one country
can't necessarily work in another
then there's the overall passenger
experience buying a single through
ticket from country a to Country C is
almost impossible in Europe Mr
connection you can forget a refund each
part of your journey is run by a
different operator focused only on their
domestic lag
now one campaigner is hoping to pressure
the EU into doing more about just these
kinds of problems by identifying some of
the worst connections as part of his
cross-border Rail Project John worth
bought a year-rail pass and spent the
summer Crossing every Border in the EU
that could be traveled by train making
95 Crossings in total and he documented
his frustrations along the way
John joins me now to talk about his
cross-border Rail Project John welcome
to the show why was it important for you
to see these examples of failed or
defunct border Connections in person
it's really important when you see those
things on the ground how those
connections really matter to people in
these border regions that it's very
important that they can actually get
across the border on an everyday basis
to go shopping to go to school or
university things like that and I wanted
to check is it actually good in some
areas or is actually this problem the
moment you cross a border by train in
Europe everything gets more complicated
and unfortunately what I ultimately
concluded is these problems are pretty
Universal whenever you cross a border in
the EU by train everything gets harder
than if you're just within one country
at the same time you highlight 20
different border crossings some shutter
due to Divergent infrastructure some
were barely traveled because of
incompatible timetables is there a
common problem or narrative to all of
these sites
basically it's very important that most
Railway companies think very nationally
they don't really want to prioritize
international railway connections per se
and so therefore all of these problems
then crop up in a variety of different
border regions it's important to say
that there are some countries that get
it right countries like Austria and
czechia for example but in many areas of
Europe these cross-border railway lines
have been disregarded not only just now
but in many cases for some considerable
decades and because we're facing a
climate change a climate change crisis
it's very very important that Europe UPS
its game on Railways and allows people
to travel from one country to another in
as Greener manner as possible and so
that's what I want from the European
Union is that the European Union should
step in to solve this manner of problems
of those sites that you visited is there
anyone that stands out as the most
egregious or absurd in terms of the lack
of connectivity
which is perhaps the most crazy of all
um if you were to go from Vilnius the
capital of Lithuania to dalgov pills the
Second City of Latvia that used to be
possible up until a few years ago but
now the train stops in the final Village
on the Lithuanian side of the Border a
village called tourmantas for just 218
habitants and the train could cost just
20 kilometers further to reach the city
on the Latvian side but it doesn't run
anymore and all you would need would be
a tank of diesel fuel in order to manage
to facilitate that connection and when I
was there there were people crossing
this border on foot because they
actually needed to get to Lithuania and
so those are the sorts of things that I
discovered it's just very sad when you
discover something like that and there
was another one as well at the border
between Portugal and Spain and where
it's a diesel train that runs on an
electrified line and between Porto and
Vigo because neither Railway company is
thought to buy electric trains for its
electrified International line and so
some of these things are very very quick
and very simple for the European Union
to step in to solve but at the moment
it's not really the political will at
that kind of practical level for the
European Union to step up and solve
those issues if these connections are so
critical why don't the rail networks
work together across border to make them
possible if there is such a demand from
people for example
it's very very difficult for that demand
to be turned into practical action and
those people into a manta house or Dow
Gap Hills who can they really ask to
solve a problem like that now for me
it's a cross-border problem so it's
europe-wide this thing afflicts pretty
much every country in the European Union
so the European Union should step in as
I see it but the European union says
okay we want Railways to work but they
take quite a kind of a hands-off
approach and that's why the European
Union has not actually said to the
governments of Latvia and Lithuania or
Portugal and Spain hey look you've got a
problem there you need to actually solve
this practically and so that's what I'm
trying to do with this project is to say
hey European Union at many different
borders you've got these types of
projects it's time to get on and fix
them all right that's John worth founder
of The cross-border Rail Project thank
you very much
thank you